Parliament held one minute of silence to  pay tribute to victims of Strasberg's  attack Parliament president Antonio  Yanni said that freedom and democracy  will always win over violence and terror  Parliament approved the 2019 budget  after MEP z-- fought for a funding boost  for young people and research around 94  percent of the EU s budget goes to  citizens cities and businesses ukrainian  filmmaker and activist oleg sentsov was  awarded the 2018 Sakharov Prize for  freedom of thought he was sentenced to  20 years in prison on charges of  plotting terrorist acts members voted on  a bilateral trade deal with Japan  covering 40% of global trade it aims to  eventually remove all tariffs on exports  to Japan around 30,000 people have died  trying to reach Europe since 2000  Parliament wants to introduce  legislation to allow asylum seekers to  apply for a visa at an EU embassy or  consulate without risking their lives